the Joe Rogan experience I'm really
happy that you came on the show me [ __ ]
is [ __ ] awesome thanks yeah I want I
mean I think I'm a correspondent Center
all these people think I'm just a
political comic and I'm like alright
jokes for any topic yeah
like but I don't like I don't like
telling political jokes but it was kind
of cool the court the the Correspondents
Dinner thing because that put you on the
map
yeah I'm very happy I did it don't get
me wrong and I stand by those jokes to
this day jokes Thanks I got the
President to tweet I yeah yeah I mean
come on was it disconcerting when that
was happening I remember that when he
tweeted at me
I like cuz he tweeted once after the
dinner and then sometime in like later
in the year like months after and I was
doing like I was doing a show in
Brooklyn I don't have Twitter on my
phone and don't know I only have it on
my computer and I am i was out in
Brooklyn dude shows and I was like
drinking hot toddies because I think I
was like feeling a little under the
weather and I was like this'll fix it
and I I was someone I kept getting
messages about this tweet and I was like
what's going on what's happening and I
then I finally saw what happened and I
was like well I guess I gotta go home so
I can tweet something back back at the
president like three hot toddies in and
I'm just like alright what can I say
what was your be best you said something
when you [ __ ] roasted him well we
actually set it on the podcast just now
no no no we actually when you did it we
were howling we believed we said what
you said on the podcast he said
something about when he I don't remember
the exact tweet he sent me but it was
like something so called comedian did
such a terrible job oh yeah I bet you'd
be on my side if I had killed a
journalist that was doing the khashoggi
stuff or whatever it was the yeah sorry
yeah yeah oh sorry I'm journalists that
had been murdered this is what he said
so-called comedian Michelle wolf by the
way best [ __ ] that is like some of
the best publicity you could ever get
yeah the president says this bomb so
badly last year at the White House
Correspondents Dinner first of all not
true
you can go listen to the recordings
people were laughing like come on this
is so crazy that you say that bomb so
balli what play it back yeah let's play
it back what's all that noise there was
parts of it where people got kind of
quiet but I remember I was like first of
all this is for the audience at home but
also I was like I'm it's one of those
rooms where you're like yeah this thing
at best there it feels fine right you
know like it's like a corporate yeah
exactly a corporate gig yeah they will
have an author instead of a comedian
what a great idea good first step and
come back of a dying evening and
tradition maybe I will go question mark
what imagine that like maybe oh god what
do you think oh please Donald I have my
new mega hat for that event I don't know
if he wrote this tweet though because
the grammar is so perfect mmm I'm like
right the - in between so and called
yeah it just feels like I was like did
someone else draft this could be
correspondence there's a correct
apostrophe yeah to the S yeah it feels
like I don't know maybe maybe he
dictated this one and someone would like
I'm gonna spell everything right yeah
well they've done various things to try
to stop him this is 2018 they've done
various things to try to slow down his
use of Twitter and social media and I do
think that there was a time when someone
else was handling it ya know but now I
think he just [ __ ] goes guns blazing
Tom straddle Rawls in a suit after it
you know it's [ __ ] wild to see I had a
dream last night and I forgot about it
until we started talking about that he
was that he was battle rapping and that
that some woman made a rap about him and
then he made a rap back at her I had a
dream maybe was cuz I knew you were
coming in here and we were probably
gonna talk about it but if we're weird
[ __ ] dream and his battle rap was
pretty good it was like pretty in people
like that it's pretty [ __ ] good like
it was a good battle rap
he said stuff sometimes when you're like
that's like that hard you know like this
but then there's other times real like
wood then you're like wait but he's the
president president sometimes [ __ ] he
says it's hilarious when he put a
[ __ ] giant Trump Tower on Greenland
when they were talking about whether or
not he was gonna we were gonna buy
Greenland he was I promise not to do
this and he shows Greenlee with a giant
gold Trump Tower and it he tweeted that
yeah that's [ __ ] hilarious it's funny
and then you're also like oh come on why
are you president
anytime he holds up a graph of any sort
I'm just like this is great there's no
y-axis you know I think it's always
stuff where you're just like this is
amazing
why are you president yeah I don't I
don't know if there's a better person
represent how crazy today is though
[Applause]